[Musique]
figaro live il est très exactement 10h47
nous sommes en direct pour ce 14 juillet
comme chaque année une cérémonie a lieu
toutefois et bien cette cérémonie est un
peu différente de la normale cette année
nous sommes en direct sur la place de la
concorde pour une cérémonie d'hommage
militaire bien évidemment mais une série
de mots ni dommages aux soignants en
cette période de crise sanitaire vous le
savez les soignants qui sont et bien sûr
le devant de la scène on l'a vu hier en
direct pendant près d'une heure avec
jean castex le premier ministre que l'on
peut voir à l'écran aux côtés d'
emmanuel macron jean castex qui est bien
à signer le ségur de la santé aux côtés
des oliviers véran ministre de la santé
et des solidarités
mais également des syndicats qui bien
pour une certaine partie d'entre eux
dans le domaine de la santé ont accepté
ce ces accords aujourd'hui changement de
contexte puisque et bien comme chaque
année a lieu les festivités les
célébrations du 14 juillet et non pas
pour un défilé militaire sur les champs
elysées comme d'habitude mais c'est une
première depuis 1945 mais plutôt pour
une cérémonie d'hommage qui a lieu sur
la place de la concorde vous le voyez
emmanuel macron et jean castex sont
arrivés sur la place de la concorde pour
saluer les différents officiers en place
ses salutations en cours et pour suivre
cette cérémonie aujourd'hui sur la page
principale du figaro sur facebook mais
également sur twitter
nous sommes en direct avec raffray
mériadeck merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes journaliste spécialisé défense est
également secrétaire général de
l'association des journalistes de
défense et vous allez bien vivre avec
nous ces cérémonies
cette cérémonie qui est un peu
particulière un peu particulière tout
doit tout d'abord dans son organisation
mais également dans son échelle un frère
bonjour thibault oui effectivement vous
l'avez vous l'avez souligné en fait
c'est un 14 juillet exceptionnel puisque
traditionnellement le défilé occuper
l'ensemble de l'avenue des champs
elysées depuis les eaux jusque vers le
bas et que
c'est très exceptionnel que ce défilé ne
suivent pas ce protocole en tout il ya
eu plusieurs fois depuis les années 80
où il ya eu des variantes je regardais
tout à l'heure en 74 défilé avait été
contre concentrés dans la baisse entre
bastille et république en 75 au cours de
vincennes en 77 à l'école militaire
en 79 à nouveau l'appui messti ya eu
aussi un défilé de nuit et cette année
donc pour les raisons liées aux os
comment dirais-je au aux mesures de
rassemblement de moins de 5000 personnes
effectivement on a décidé de le
concentrer sur le 8,6 hectares de la
place de la concorde la plus grande de
paris
[Musique]
non
alors le président de république a salué
hautes autorités militaires à savoir
donc il était accompagné du chef
d'état-major des armées le général
françois lecointre
comme on voit que le mans ne voit plus
le général le vrai qui tourne le dos au
président qui est nouvelle en matière de
paris qui d'ailleurs va quitter ses
fonctions fin juillet c'est son dernier
défilé son cinquième et dernier défilé
il a également salué en descendant du
command car les patrons des armées de
mémoire de la gauche vers la droite il y
avait les général burkhard thierry
burkhard qui est le nouveau patron des
armées l'armée terre depuis un an
il y avait ensuite le patron de la
marine le général
l'amiral christophe prazuck et qui lui
aussi quitte ses fonctions à la fin du
mois de juillet en quelques semaines qui
d'ailleurs le président a rendu un
hommage appuyé gaspard l'hôtel de
brienne et puis le dernier sur la
montagne droite c'est fait les patrons
l'armée d'heure le général philippe
lavigne
en fait ce qui est intéressant à
souligner c'est que ce 14 juillet marque
un tournant dans l'équipe dans les
équipes militaires qui vont entourer qui
entourent le président macron à
commencer par le plus proche
collaborateur militaire du président ma
devant le chef d'état major particulier
du président
c'était donc on l'a vu tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs il est barbu il a été forte
corpulence il s'appelle l'amiral
ça va me revenir gym échappe tout d'un
coup c'était le le chef d'état major
particulier qui sortant qui va être
remplacé son successeur a été déjà nommé
il s'appelle l'amiral roland
sombre avenir c'est un sous marinier
réputé très très faim qui a assuré la
succession entre les deux présidents
entre françois hollande et manuel des
grands
demandant le 1er régiment d'infanterie
de cambridge
présents sont un petit peu limité en
terme de nombre en raison de la crise
sanitaire
en revanche ils sont bien présents dans
le tchat sur bien d'autres pages sur la
page principale du figaro sur facebook
mais également sur twitter où nous vous
diffusons ces images merci à tous vous
êtes nombreux à être avec nous
aujourd'hui je vais vous saluer tout
d'abord dans le chat bien je vais je
vous remercie à tous d'être avec nous
bonjour chris crise par exemple
alors je vais essayer voilà comme ça
vous pourrez suivre aussi ces images
bonjour à vous crise crise bonjour
également dominique pougeoise claudette
du beau bonjour à chevalier de vannes
karadoc et toute sa famille qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui oggi annoni joss
onion only five philippe de lierre alors
je ne pourrais pas tous vous salue et
puisque vous êtes actuellement 1600 a
donc gardé sur la page principale du sur
la page facebook du figaro seulement
alors que vous êtes aussi tout aussi
nombreux nous regarder sur la page
principale du figaro et sur twitter mon
cul je vous remercie
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à poser toutes
vos questions à fréha mériadeck y ait
dans le journal spécialisé défense mais
également secrétaire général de
l'association des journalistes de
défense qui pourra vous répondre
notamment sur le déploiement des troupes
que l'on va pouvoir observer est sûr
aussi l'organisation de cette cérémonie
d'hommage aux soignants vous le voyez
les salutations continue avec cette
année cinq pays à l'honneur à frais à
commencer par l'allemagne
alors effectivement on à l'allemagne la
suisse l'autriche et du luxembourg ce
sont les états qui ont participé à
l'accueil de nos de nos concitoyens qui
avait été contaminée qui était en
réanimation pour la plupart d'entre eux
dans les hôpitaux de l'est de la france
on peut citer les chiffres l'allemagne à
récupérer 120 patients français en mars
et avril entre le 21 mars et le 4 avril
l'autriche de patience est symbolique
mais voilà le luxembourg onze patients
et la suisse 27 patients français
patients qui ont été transférées
essentiellement par des moyens aériens
français mais également par des moyens
aériens militaires allemands notamment
un a400m cela classe que nous on appelle
l'atlas qui est là
transport stratégique qui remplace
l'antédiluvien transall et entre temps
pendant que je vous parlais gvg
retrouver le nom du chef d'état major
particulier du président le marin barbu
l'amiral barbu que vous avez vus à
l'écran tout à l'heure l'amiral rogel je
disais tout à l'heure il est d'un de ce
qui restait de plus longtemps en poste
dans ce poste depuis 2016 jusqu'à donc
2020 il a été prolongé de mémoire au
moins une fois
c'est dire la confiance et le rôle que 7
à meyrals qui avait qui avait auparavant
été patron de la marine chef d'état
major de la marine a pu avoir auprès du
président on sait que le président suit
de très près les dossiers militaires il
annote lui-même un certain nombre de
dossiers de sa propre main voilà et donc
pour le remplacer c'est non plus un sous
marinier mai 1,1 sur fassiez l'amiral
roland barbu lui aussi d'ailleurs qui
prend ce poste il était héron son nom
est apparu ces derniers temps dans les
médias parce que il était en charge de
la force d'action navale à toulon
c'est à dire il était le responsable
organique de la flotte de surface et il
était notamment le responsable du porte
avions charles de gaulle
on en a un petit peu parlé durant la
période de contamination de l'équipage
au coc u19 et puisque et puisqu'on en
est aux hommes signalons cinétique
on attend la nomination évidemment du
remplaçant du chef d'état-major de la
marine l'amiral prazuck
quelques noms circulent déjà et un autre
responsable important pour les
opérations à changer celui qu'on appelle
le sous-chef opérations à l'état major
des armées
et il n'était toutefois s'était occupée
par le général de cinq ans
un terrien des forces spéciales pendant
de nombreuses années il devrait être
remplacé par le général stéphane ville
qui est un aviateur un pilote de chasse
qui a notamment été le numéro deux de
l'opération barkan en 2016 2017 si je
mes souvenirs sont exacts
alors que les membres d'un autre
gouvernement sont assis pour le début de
cette cérémonie
on va revenir sur tout de suite sur un
sur ce qu'on peut le voir à l'écran
avant cela je vais vous saluer vous qui
nous souhaiter une bonne fête nationale
bonjour jessica ben behe sur facebook
bonjour également kelvin goh il le dit
bonne fête nationale française vive la
france va merci à tous n'hésitez pas à
nous passer vos salutations bonjour
aussi à jo sua mcneely qui nous
regardent d'australie bonjour à vous
bush bouchard jean christophe qui me
salue également voilà merci à tous c'est
vrai que j'ai vu ce message tout à
l'heure alors ce qu'on peut déjà ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'en tout cas
beaucoup de nos internautes faits sont
assez interloqué par le fait que bien
les membres du gouvernement n'est pas
leur masque alors on peut dire que les
personnes qu'on voit ici qui n'ont pas
leur masse que l'on eut pendant tous les
déplacements
vu les anglais lors de leur arrivée ici
sur la place de la concorde
ne vous inquiétez pas et vous voyez
qu'en tout cas les distances de sécurité
sont bel et bien respecté même si ça
s'est plutôt des usages c'est espacement
entre les places pour le voir alors
désormais on voit bien un blindé arrivée
place de la concorde avec et bien ses
membres de l'armée donc c'est un charlot
de la première guerre mondiale si je ne
m'abuse
mais là j'avoue que faudra spécialistes
et la voilà et là en fait on à la
présentation des différents garder
différents garde au drapeau voilà cette
formation que l'on voit à l'écran
maintenant on a donc en général ce sont
des officiers et sous-officiers qui ont
été méritants qui porte le drapeau de
l'ensemble des régions qui sont offert
des formations qui sont représenté
autour de 7,2 cette place de la concorde
on a tu en train de retrouver les
chiffres pendant que je vis parlent pour
ne pas vous dire de bêtises on a trente
gardes au drapeau qui sont présentes de
ce matin voilà on voit les chars
effectivement c'est bien ça alors c'est
1939 en fait de la résistance
ce mardi m
reprend comme on se devait de les
victoires sur terre sur mer et dans les
airs le général
et en afrique en asie et on
18 juin 1940 il ya un excellent livre
d'ailleurs qui est sorti sur les
compagnons de la libération qui explique
comment en fait est bien cet appel n'a
pas forcément été entendu par beaucoup
mais qu'on l'ait entendu ou pas beaucoup
de français beaucoup de militaires
avaient donc décidé de rejoindre londres
pour continuer le connard
[Musique]
ce que l'on peut dire peut-être pour
rassurer les gens c'est quand est de
format choisi exceptionnel
et tient compte comme je le disais au
début de de là la doctrine les décrets
légaux sur l'organisation des
manifestations il ya moins de 5000
personnes 2180 dix et quelques
militaires et le reste essentiellement
composé d'invités enfin du gouvernement
bien sûr de tout le personnel de
sécurité des médias etc et des invités
de l'elysée c'est l'elysée qui a géré
les habitations on retrouve parmi les
invités de nombreux professionnels de la
santé et l'ensemble de ces professions
qui ont contribué à la résidence le mot
est à la mode de notre pays durant ces
deux mois et demi de crise depuis les
métiers les plus simples les plus
manuels jusque métier peut-être médecins
etc
[Musique]
comme vous l'avez compris je ne suis pas
un spécialiste des chars mais j'ai eu
l'occasion et je conseille à tous vos
aînés internautes cet été s'ils le
veulent et le peuvent d'aller faire un
tour au musée des blindés de saumur
c'est un des plus beaux musées du monde
dans lequel il ya des des spécimens
exceptionnels des chars depuis les
années 14 15 16 17 jusqu'à de nos jours
alors que là on voit à l'écran
évidemment là la croix de lorraine
[Musique]
dessinée avec les représentants de
l'ensemble de la dite toute la diversité
des armées on voit d'ailleurs je pense
que c'est un représentant du 1er
régiment de spahis qui porte la longue
voilà au premier plan à droite la longue
cape blanche
c'est un des régiments héritiers des
traditions de l'armée d'afrique
celle qui a été d'ailleurs mises à
l'honneur par geneviève darrieussecq la
ministre lyne anciens combattants à
travers un fascicule recensant une
centaine de morts deux héros de cette
armée d'afrique morts au combat
issus de nos anciennes colonies
d'afrique de l'ouest essentiellement en
afrique centrale
l'idée c'était de remettre ce fascicule
aux parlementaires pour les inciter à
honorer de leur nom nos places et nos
rues de village si ce n'est pas déjà
fait ainsi que de leur dresser des
statuts alors après on a une question
sur facebook de jérémy letellier qu'on
salue grand merci d'être avec nous qui
nous demandent si le dernier défilé à
huis clos était en juillet 1940 alors ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que là ce que l'on
observe aujourd'hui c'est une première
depuis 1945
puisque eh bien ce n'est pas un défilé
sur les champs-elysées la cas auquel on
assiste
mais plutôt à une cérémonie d'hommage
aux soignants qui
bien se fait sur la place de la concorde
sans défilé et surtout avec beaucoup
moins de spectateurs que d'habitude près
de deux fois moins
en fait je permet de rectifier un tout
petit peu en réalité il n'ya pas de
défilé motorisé mais il y aura bien un
il y aura bien trois défilés
un défilé à pied des troupes à pied qui
sera évidemment concentré danser sur
cette place mais également de défilé
aérien avec un peu moins il est vrai
d'appareils un défilé avec des avions et
un défilé n'est pas ce qu'on appelle les
voilures tournantes sur les hélicoptères
avec un peu moins d'hélicoptères mais il
y aura quand même terrain deux des fils
aériens donc voilà format exceptionnel
certes mais les codes et le le
gouverneur militaire de paris le général
le reiki est le grand maître de
cérémonie laver avait bien insisté sur
le fait que les codes du 14 juillet
l'école militaire du 14 juillet était
tous bien respecté c'est une
c'est une cérémonie qui est qui en fait
codifié et on l'aimé on ne peut pas en
fait
comment dirais-je sortir de ces codes
comme ça en l'occurrence n'est pas le
cas et par ailleurs il ya eu d'autres
défilés dans les endroits clos
donc je ne me citait notamment un défilé
de nuit il ya eu un défilé à l'école
militaire il y a eu un défilé
les premiers défilés étaient sur
l'hippodrome de longchamp
voilà
[Musique]
alors effectivement ça c'est ça c'est
pas une tradition c'est offrir tout cas
c'est une tradition qui est très récente
sauf si je me trompe mais je pense que
cette françois hollande qui a dû
inaugurer ce se forme à un moment où
d'ailleurs françois hollande était un
peu chahuté dans les sondages il a il
l'a fait et il a fait comme com a su
faire très bien manier le maquereau
d'ailleurs se rapprocher des armées pour
se représidentialiser à l'époque
emmanuel macron lui avait endossé très
rapidement son uniforme de chef des
armées car je vous rappelle que en
france
constitutionnellement parlant c'est le
président qui est chef des armées n'ont
pas le premier ministre est en fait
mails magron depuis je crois de l'été
2010 est le 13 le 13 juillet 2017
prononce un discours à l'hôtel de
brienne la veille 14 juillet je vous
rappelle d'ailleurs que le premier
discours qu'il avait propre et là qu'il
avait prononcé le 13 juillet 2017 avait
été celui au cours duquel il avait eu
des mots durs voire même désagréables à
l'encontre du chef d'état major des
armées de l'époque qui sait qui était
générale lecointe qui avait amené ce
dernier à quelques jours après à imposer
le képi comme on dit chez militaire a
démissionné j'avoue que hier le
président a eu un tout autre ton à
l'endroit des armées il a prononcé à nos
nombreuses reprises de mots merci
il a dit plusieurs fois merci et
effectivement moi ce que je ce que j'ai
noté pendant cette crise c'est que quand
le président le 25 mars
depuis colmar a annoncé l'ouverture de
l'opération résilience les armées ont
honte immédiatement emboîté le pas il a
en quelque sorte appuyer sur un bouton
et les armées ont réagi et donc il
pouvait bien leur dire merci
si dans le 25 mars
depuis colmar a annoncé l'ouverture
entreprises sont susceptibles de
compenser les ferments de dispersion que
son pop porte en lui-même que notre pays
tel qu'il est parmi les autres tels
qu'ils sont tous cas de danger mortel
viser haut et se sentir droit bref à mon
sens la france ne peut être la france
sans la bande heures je travaille les
bases que nous souhaitons donner aux
institutions renouvelé de la france ces
vases elles sont définies par les trois
devises des français libres nous disons
honneur et patrie entendant par là que
la nation ne pourra revivre dans la
victoire et susciter que dans le culte
de sa propre grandeur
nous disons liberté égalité fraternité
parce que notre volonté est de rester
fidèle aux principes démocratiques
nous disions libération
car si notre effort ne serait se
terminer avant la défaite de lundi doit
avoir comme aboutissement
chacun des français on conditions telles
qu'il lui soit possible de vivre et de
travailler dans la dignité et la
sécurité
il faut que la défense de la france la
france est un pays comme la france
s'il lui arrive de faire la guerre il
faut que ce soit sa guerre il faut que
son effort soit son effort s'il en était
autrement notre pays serait en
contradiction avec tout ce qu'il est
depuis ses origines avec son rôle avec
les styles qu'il a de lui-même
oui tout à fait un jeu j'en profite pour
demander est ce qu on voit l'état
l'école de la grande école militaire de
leur metteur et j'en profite pour
signaler qu'ils portent on voit une ce
qu'on appelle une fourragères 1
un morceau de tissu vert à leur épaule
gauche est en fait cette fourragères
alors a été remise officiellement a été
remise officiellement à l'école spéciale
militaire de saint-cyr à la ministre des
armées il ya quelques semaines dans une
cérémonie officielle à l'école militaire
7 fourragères en fait c'est celle des
compagnons de la libération
si je fais pas d'erreur l'ordre créé par
le général de gaulle dès 1940 pour
récompenser les braves
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour redonner le
titre de l'ouvragé qui m'échappait tout
à l'heure les compagnons de la
libération de la 13e division légère des
visions domi brigade par an de la légion
étrangère signé dans riveill édition
mareuil qui qui racontent ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure tous ces hommes
ces militaires qui se sont engagés en
ayant entendu une fois d'ailleurs
l'appel du général de gaulle qui se sont
engagés pour dans la résistance armée à
l'occupant merci mais avec cette
précision et merci à vous sur twitch
également que je n'ai pas encore saluer
et je vais tout de suite
remédier à cela bonjour à mon kiki lol
vous nous dites que alors les pétards en
effet ce sont interdits toutefois
j'avais vu ces questions passées tout à
l'heure les traditionnels feux
d'artifice du 14 juillet ne serait pas
annulé ils auront bel et bien lieu
toutefois le concert et les feux
d'artifice seront un bienfait sans
public
voilà pour en tout cas l'organisation
bonjour à vous clair que j'ai plaisir à
retrouver cela fait de tentes
c'est cette cérémonie aujourd'hui
bonjour à vous également unissent
closing raid arles 13 également va
n'hésitez pas à commenter je vois
notamment je vous sers vit bel et bien
deviner quelles étaient les modèles du
shark nous avons vu et et qui nous
interroger un petit peu au début mais
vous l'avez bien bel et bien trouvé
félicitations n'hésitez pas à nous dire
si vous êtes de fins connaisseurs des
différents des différents des
différences appareils que nous allons
voir a commenté dans le chat on essaiera
prendre tous vos commentaires on vous en
remercie en tout cas je voulais suivre
ces images alors que le défilé aérien
commence tout juste
j'en profite thibault pour peut-être
faire une précision au cas c'était pas
clair en 2017 le 13 juillet 2010 est
effectivement c'était le général de
gibier quitté shelter major des armées
qui avaient été entre guillemets
remercié par le président macro
aujourd'hui c'est bien le général
lecointe qui est depuis d'ailleurs cet
épisode là le patron des armées
si ce n'était pas clair voilà cette
précision et il est donc là comme je
disais on a on a donc c'est le premier
défilé aérien
alors on a vu à l'écran alors voilà on a
vu à l'écran l'a400m la la classe voilà
c'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui là en ce
moment on voit sans doute un a330 mrtt
l'avion greek vous voyez qui est en fait
un ravitailleur un appareil très
important car cette cet appareil qui
permet aux avions de chasse d'être de
comme on dirait en avant par une
permanence dans le ciel d'une part lors
de la houle nous avons des opérations et
surtout surtout d'assurer la continuité
la permanence de la dissuasion nucléaire
la dissuasion la partie aérienne de la
dissuasion nucléaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle les sur la
france en particulier a investi d'un
renouvellement de sa flotte de
ravitailleurs
[Musique]
hélas
voilà on voi avions hawk eye qui est une
véritable tour de contrôle aérienne on
voit d'ailleurs le radar dôme qui tourne
il est très encadrée je pense on voit
pas venir mais par deux rafale en fait
on a le même type d'appareil aux
miniatures qui est basé qui décolle et
qui atterrit sur les porte-avions le
hawk eye
magnifique
je confirme il s'agit ouais j'ai un
doute
c'est un mirage c'est des mirage 2000
par noah ouais ce sont des mirage 2000
[Musique]
je
beaucoup
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on peut dire aujourd'hui que
l'armée de l'air est engagé dans les
opérations elles aussi de manière
importante puisque l'armée de l'air
assure la couverture aérienne de
l'opération barque à naucelle
ces chasseurs sont basées à la fois
n'djamena donc à l'est dispositif ce qui
lui permet d'ailleurs de couvrir le nord
le fin le sud de la libye et le nord de
la république centrafricaine au passage
qui sont deux points stratégiques
majeures ses avions de chasse ont
également basé à niamey au niger
1 ce qui lui permet la d'intervenir très
rapidement évidemment sur la zone
opérationnelle du mali et en particulier
la zone des trois frontières qui situe
dans le dans le sud est du mali entre à
cheval avec le burkina faso le niger
alors voilà ça c'est un atlantique 2 de
la marine c'est un avion qui avait été
conçu pour chasser les traquer les sous
marins soviétiques en atlantique nord en
particulier et que qui a repris
d'ailleurs du service puisque la flotte
sous marine russe est de nouveau assez
active mais qu'on emploie aujourd'hui
pour patrouiller au dessus de
l'immensité désertique du sahel c'est un
avion qui est capable de voler de
mémoire une dizaine d'heures les
spécialistes ne m'en voudront pas d'être
plus précis au dessus du désert avec une
capacité évidemment de renseignements
grâce à des moyens électroniques mais
également de frappe
ils emportent en fait des bols
dans ce match
alors que l'ensemble du gouvernement est
bel et bien présent vous le voyez sur
ces images avec notamment la maire de
paris anne hidalgo
gérard larcher président du sénat bien
évidemment on a vu olivier ferrand qui
était sur le devant de l'affiché hier
pour la signature du ségur de la santé
alors qu on entend d'autres d'autres
appareils ne survolait j'espère qu'on
aura les images là pour vraiment nous
avons la tribune officielle
on va essayer de suivre cela en tout cas
on peut voir ce monsieur barbu que nous
essayons de trouver tout à l'heure on
peut le voir à l'écran ici et on va
essayer de voilà de décrire un petit peu
ce gouvernement nouvelle nouvelle
génération après son remaniement on a
notamment marlène schiappa qu'on peut
observer qui est désormais au côté de
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
vous l'avez suivi
[Musique]
voilà peu d'image pour le moment de ce
qui se passe dans les airs mais vous
inquiétez pas des images de la société
de presse qui nous fournissent ces
images bel et bien arrivé alors là
thibault a confirmé mais je pense qu'au
centre c'est un a400m flanc kg et à
gauche alors à gauche à l'écran je pense
que c'est un jeu non je vous dire une
bêtise donc voilà est à droite ça va
être un casa 260 c des appareils qui ont
été utilisés pour transfert des
transferts réaliser des transferts de
deux personnes de citoyens de gens
contaminés avec des kits montrent en
fait des clips dans ses avions qu'on
transforme en véritable ambulances de
l'air et on peut ainsi transporter des
patients en état de réanimation donc
véritablement choqué sur de longues
distances
[Musique]
c'est ça donc on avait aussi un âne
herculès et puis un avion de
ravitaillement aussi en vol un cas c
130j les spécialistes
et la raison que ce sont en jaune des
canadairs qu'on reconnaît et en bleu en
blanc un dash q400 qui est aussi un
avion qui sert notamment pour lutter
contre les feux de forêt
[Musique]
je vous propose très rapidement de
revenir sur le programme de cette
journée puisque c'est une journée
particulièrement actif tout d'abord à la
fin de cette cérémonie nous aurons un
discours d' emmanuel macron vous pourrez
suivre en direct sur figaro live
n'hésitez pas à rester avec nous mais
ensuite nous pouvons observer dans cette
journée un peu particulière bien tout
d'abord des manifestations ce n'est pas
coutume en 14 juillet mais bien on sait
déjà et bien à 10h01 de 10 heures à 12
heures un rassemblement d gilet jaune et
est appelée devant l'igpn à 14 heures un
rassemblement mais soignants devra lui
être faites de la place de la république
à la place de la bastille ça on pourra
vous le faire suivre alors ce sera pas
forcément en direct mais marque quand je
donne rendez vous sur twitter et sur la
page principale du figaro pour suivre
toutes les actualités de ce
rassemblement au lendemain de la
signature des accords du ségur de la
santé vous le savez bien
ces négociations ne sont pas forcément
en grande pompe pour tout l'ensemble du
personnel des soignants et de l'hôpital
public
ce que l'on sait également et bien et je
vous le disais tout à l'heure c'est que
à 10 à 23 heures comme tous les jours et
bien comme tous les toutes les heures à
toutes les années plus tôt le fameux
feu d'artifice et le concert du 14
juillet auront bel et bien lieu deux
fois ce sera sans que le guide vous
pourrez donc suivre cela en direct sur
les différentes chaînes de télévision et
si je vais je vais aller voir tout de
suite et je vais vous préciser cela mais
si nous avons les images et bien je vous
propose de les suivre en direct sur foot
et en live avec moi ce soir
je n'en suis pas sûr c'est un peu plus
compliqué en général mais sinon bah
voila je vous donne rendez vous une fois
n'est pas coutume à la télévision ces
différentes festivités alors qu'on
revient sur la place de la concorde
mériadeck poursuivre bien la super pole
à la suite mais cette cérémonie avec un
événement toujours très attendue la
musique de la légion étrangère
vous savez que la légion étrangère d'ici
là un pas particulier qui est plus lent
que celui des des troupes
conventionnelles de la régulière comme
on dit voilà musique de légion étrangère
qui va ouvrir le tableau au sol dans
quelques instants
mais bon ça la formule des commentaires
dans la tribune présidentielle légion
étrangère on peut on peut en profiter
puisque le le débat est d'actualité pour
dire que c'est sylvia une troupe l'armée
en général qui est un le reflet de la de
la société la légion étrangère depuis
par conception qui est une troupe qui
intègre un ce sont c'est une troupe à
thégra triste elle recrute des hommes
des jeunes hommes qui viennent du monde
entier
évidemment pour la plupart d'entre eux
arrivent en france sans même parler un
mot de français
elle les recrutent elle reprend le
français est leur apprend les codes de
la légion étrangère et ses hommes
deviennent français par le sang versé
c'est une belle s'est connus mais se
voit là ça mérite d'être appelé
[Musique]
le président de la république rappelé
hier soir un chiffre fort cette année
alors je pense parler du 14 entre le 14
juillet 2019 et 14e et 2020 les armées
ont connu la mort soit l'ennemi pour
reprendre son expression soit l'or en
mission commandée de 31 des leurs c'est
un chiffre important qui qui illustre le
prix le le crédit payés par les armées
par notre société à la défense à la dea
notre défense à la fois où un prêt sur
tous les avant postes qui sont
évidemment le sel puisque c'est là où
c'est là où l'on meurt à l'ennemi
aujourd'hui souligné forme français je
rappelle qu'il ya en novembre dernier
de nos soldats qui sont morts dans le
crash de deux hélicoptères de combat
deux hélicoptères au mali vous avez pu
suivre
c'est c'est cet hommage national aux
invalides en direct sur figaro live moi
ce que je vous propose également ses de
revenir sur et bien sûr la mort
justement au combat de à l'âge de 21 ans
de la 1ère classe du 1er classe de 1ère
classe pardon kevin clémente deuxième
légionnaire du régiment de la légion
étrangère décédé en décéder au mali
voilà on avait pu suivre également cet
hommage national en mai dernier sur
figaro live ça c'est une particularité
aussi des troupes françaises alors
évidemment aujourd'hui ce matin c'est un
hommage aux combattants combattants du
cofide à ceux qui les ont appuyés donc
les les armées à travers l'opération
résilience au plus fort de cette
opération résilience on a compté jusqu'à
une douzaine de missions quotidiennes
pour les armées entre les évacuations
sanitaires par les airs le la protection
d'endroits dans lequel étaient stockés
par exemple des masques le la protection
de convois logistiques ont affronté
jusqu'à une douzaine mais en fait ce qui
fait surtout la spécificité de nos
armées aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles sont
quasiment aujourd'hui encore les seuls à
payer le prix du sang pour la stabilité
et pour la lutte antiterroriste la
stabilité du sahel à la lutte
antiterroriste au sahel
en janvier dernier il y a eu lieu le
sommet de pau au cours de laquelle le
président macron et ses cinq partenaires
africains du g5 celle le mali le burkina
faso le niger le tchad et la mauritanie
ont décider de comment dirais-je de de
réaliser un sursaut militaire en mettant
davantage d'hommes au sol en allant
chercher les terroristes là où il s'est
situé en particulier dans ce fameux
cette fameuse zone des trois frontières
et en six mois d'obtenir les résultats
mais on est avec les résultats au prix
de la sueur et du sang
aujourd'hui les troupes françaises pour
hockenheim nomadisent pendant plusieurs
semaines dans le désert par des
températures extrêmes 45 50 degrés elles
sont ravitaillées uniquement souvent par
air en eau et en nourriture est
évidemment quand on va chercher l'ennemi
on peut prendre ses pertes comme on dit
et en particulier lors de vos passages
de convois
certains véhicules saute sur ce qu'on
appelle les engins explosifs improvisés
les aider ou mieux des en anglais qui
sont en fait larmes du pauvre
face à cette arme est à la fois rustique
et technologique
ça c'est vraiment la marque de fabrique
[Musique]
il me semble me rappeler que souvent ça
c'est une régression qui a lieu plus tôt
en fin de défilé dans les défilés
traditionnels
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais
souvent après les défilés des troupes à
pied et motorisées qui descendent des
champs elysées le défilé se termine par
une aubade et de temps en temps des les
musiques qui sont militaires qui sont
présentes
effectivement interprète des musiques et
des morceaux choisis qui varie un peu de
traditionnellement ce militaire était le
gars
la cérémonie
le trump étaient présents et l'ensemble
des militaires qui jouait devant vit
avec annie titre
vous avez raison
[Musique]
hier le 4 nov le 13 juillet le président
macron a également passé en revue les
points chauds du globe
il a évidemment il a évidemment
mentionner l'opération par cannes il a
dit il a employé le terme de victoires à
propos des six mois écoulés dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure mais il a dit
également qu'il y aurait un prochain
rendez vous à la fin de l'année
voir si ces victoires avait pu être
transformé dépasser pour marquer des
points sur le plan de la restauration de
la paix le retour des états et
gouvernants et enfin des de la puissance
publique et des états dans les pays dans
les zones délaissées sacema premier plan
pour qu'on sait qu' il y aura un premier
rendez-vous saïdia en fin d'année il a
aussi évidemment insisté alors un peu
sur la kz1 indo pacifique en expliquant
qu'il veillerait que nous veillerons que
les armes et veillerait à la liberté de
la souveraineté
il pense notamment à la liberté au droit
au droit international de navigation
dans les mers non souveraine et puis il
a surtout insisté sur la méditerranée en
disant que c'était l'une des priorités
des prochains mois et que c'était là où
se concentrait actuellement ce que la
revue stratégique de 2017 avait comment
dirais-je avait décrit à savoir le
retour des états puissance l'emploi de
la force voire de l'intimidation
on pourra reparler si vous voulez mais
là ça fait référence directement à notre
marine qui a une qui a eu qui a eu dont
un des bâtiments a et a fait l'objet
d'une passe d'armes
il ya quelques semaines mi juillet avec
un bâtiment turc au large de misrata en
[Musique]
oui je suis en train de chanterac
commence vous permet de retrouver les
chiffres exacts mais bref vous les avez
donné voilà donc là on voit à l'écran
donc le défilé des hélicoptères avec on
a vu je vais essayer d'en trouver les
images mais on a vu je crois des
hélicoptères d'attaqué non alors ça
voilà le saas et le caïman
le nh90 tu sais le surnom industrielle
le caïman qui est le nouvel hélicoptère
de transport de l'armée de terre qui est
un véritable bijou j'ai eu l'occasion de
voler sur caïmans et de me poser sur la
piste d'atterrissage entre guillemets
d'une frégate de française en
méditerranée
c'est incroyable c'était cet hélicoptère
d'une stabilité d'une douceur
il est bourré d'électronique ces voix là
c'est vraiment un danger incroyable qui
qui a servi justement à transporter nos
nos compatriotes français qui étaient
dans les hôpitaux de l'est pour les les
transférer dans d'autres hôpitaux et à
droite on voit un dauphin qui est un
hélicoptère qui sert à la marine en
particulier
et voilà voilà ça c'est le fameux
hélicoptères tigre est également un
acteur formidable incroyable tous les
pilotes ce look c'est cet hélicoptère
qui évidemment aussi bourré
d'électronique mais qui iront d'énormes
services pour appuyer les troupes au sol
il est doté en particulier dont on ne
voit pas dans le nez d'un canon qui qui
sert beaucoup pour appuyer de troupes au
sol
[Musique]
ça ce sont les les hélicoptères
tellement connu que j'oublie sur leur
nom et je vais le retrouver la bête de
somme de l'armée de l'armée de terre les
pumas voilà ce sont des pumas à droite
et à gauche
un caïman donc deux génération
d'hélicoptères qui sont sur les échos
pierre sont sur engagé sur employés et
d'ailleurs les gens de l'aviation légère
de l'armée de terre de la latte
souhaiterait bien aussi avoir les fameux
chine où vous savez c ces hélicoptères
qui ont à rotor à chaque bout de leur
carlingue mais qui sont aujourd'hui ce
sont aujourd'hui des chez nous que
britanniques qui sont dépêchés au mali
et lison en fait une grande qualité
c'est qu'ils ont une capacité d'emport
de charge qui est très importante
beaucoup plus importante que ce que nos
hélicoptères et qui permet en fait qui
rend d'énormes services à nos troupes
qui leur permet d'avoir beaucoup de
réactivité quand il détecte une
embuscade ou un poids logistique et demi
et qui nous manquait beaucoup
alors je rebondis sur ce commentaire
mériadeck qui nous parvient stéphanie de
l'or merci et vous nous soumettez ce
commentaire mono dit les caméras
devraient faire des plans sur les
invités des tribunes des invités
exceptionnels du président notamment la
tribune bleus alors moi je vais parler
un petit peu de ses invités
exceptionnels puisque cette année on
vous le savez est bien la cérémonie et
en hommage aux soignants et donc eh bien
on était invités spécialement pour
assister à l'événement des soignants des
fonctionnaires des associatives des
membres de la société civile des
personnalités engagées durant la crise
ça c'est ce que nous a affirmé à
l'elysée on aura également aussi un
panel de famille de soignants qui ont
perdu la vie durant l'épidémie
et on voit à l'écran si je ne me trompe
pas le général bailleux de marisy qui
est l'adjoint du gouverneur militaire de
paris qui en fait alors le gouverneur
militaire de paris le patron du défilé
le général bailleux de marisy et le et
le commandant des troupes en quelque
sorte
[Musique]
pour les observateurs non averti c'est
toujours intéressant noté même si
maintenant si bien connu mais tous les
officiers les soldats d'ailleurs qui
défilent aujourd'hui
depuis quelques années ont tous en fait
un certain nombre de décorations à
l'image de celle que porte le chef
d'état major des armées
cela en fait illustre bien que nous
avons aujourd'hui une armée qui est une
arme et d'engagement une armée qui fait
la guerre qui fait les opérations et ça
c'est vraiment une spécificité française
en europe les britanniques étaient aussi
comme comme les français mais ils ont
beaucoup perdu à la suite de leurs
aventures et que les américains en irak
à telle enseigne aujourd'hui c'est une
armée qui a beaucoup de mal à retrouver
à retrouver son rang et la france est
avec les etats unis aujourd'hui une les
armes et les plus engagés au monde sait
qu'il lui donne il a d'abord beaucoup de
légitimité et qui donne beaucoup
légitimité ou chef d'état-major des
armées pour parler avec ses homologues
mais aussi avec les autorités politiques
françaises voilà un allemand le triche
[Musique]
la suisse l'autriche le luxembourg et
l'allemagne
[Musique]
en fait la formation le les formations
sont normés ce sont les gardes au
drapeau la suisse suisse où le la
réserve est très importante la réserve a
été mobilisé en suisse c'est une armée
le noyau de l'armée professionnelle
suisse est très très très petit et
l'armée de réserve est très importante
elle était mobilisée pour apporter sa
contribution à la lutte contre le
coleader et là maintenant on a le défilé
des différentes écoles qui sont toutes
représentées traditionnellement alors là
je vois pas les scolytes l uniforme bleu
c'est peut-être là non ça c'est l'école
de la santé je pense avec le caducée
voilà donc ces board c'est lyon
aujourd'hui l'école de la santé une
école prestigieuse qui forme le
personnel soignant notamment les
médecins militaires qui sont vraiment ça
la crème de la crème
l'élite de l'élite militaire médicale
quand ils sont recrutés seulement
aujourd'hui il ya un déficit notamment
de médecins aussi dans les services de
santé des armées il ya un an environ une
centaine de postes de médecins pour une
bonne et simple raison c'est que ces
femmes et ces hommes
son temps sur engagés eux aussi car à
chaque fois que l'on engage des
militaires on engage également un sierra
soutien de santé ces hommes et femmes
passent quatre mois deux mois trois mois
quatre mois au sahel par exemple dans
les mêmes conditions que nous sommes
évidemment quand ils y vont enfin quand
il entre dans cette voie militaire il ya
un écart important de salaires avec leur
caméra de qui font carrière dans le
public ou dans le privé d'ailleurs est
donc souvent ce qui se passe c'est que
ces jeunes sont formés se forment sous
l'uniforme font quelques années et puis
une fois que ils ont bien tourné en
opération une fois par an jusqu'à plus
une fois par an pour ceux qui tournent
le plus eh bien il quitte l'armée et
voilà il ya un problème d'attractivité
le président en a parlé hier d'ailleurs
dans son discours il a dit qu il n'a
donné rendez vous à la fin d'année en
décembre aux armées pour la réforme du
système de rémunération des militaires
[Musique]
c'est une école si je me trompe c'est
l'école militaire interarmes qui forment
donc les officiers qui sort du rang qui
ont été engagées qui sont engagés en
particulier comme sous-officier d'activ
ce sont des officiers dons qui serviront
comme le temps et qui seront plus âgés
que les jeunes syriens qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure qui sorte qu'ils sortent eux de
deux ans de préparation me des en
préparation après le bac
[Musique]
mais on a pu le voir mériadeck la place
de l'armée dans le soin avec bien peu
plus fort de l'épidémie de vide 19 avec
la mise en place d'un hôpital militaire
à melo c'est quelque chose de pas banal
d'assez exceptionnel et qui a été
extrêmement important alors que le pic
de l'épidémie était un peu plus fort et
puis voilà et surtout pour la prise en
charge notamment de cet épicentre
alors comme je l'étais tout à l'heure
nos armées sont sur engagiez et par voie
de conséquence notre service de santé
des armées aujourd'hui à une expérience
incroyable en matière de traumatismes de
guerre de blessures de guerre de grands
brûlés de jean amputé d'ailleurs ces
blessés là sont donc pris en charge sur
le théâtre ensuite évacué par les
falcons médicalisé dont on a vu qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure
accueillie notamment à percy à l'hôpital
d'instruction des armées de percy à
celui bégin à vincennes
percy à clamart desjardins scène et
ailleurs où sont soignés par des
spécialistes puis pris en charge par
l'institution nationale des invalides
notamment qui est spécialisée dans
depuis la première guerre mondiale dans
la réparation des blessés de guerre
ce qui leur donne évidemment de
spécialité mais ces services de santé
des armées a subi les effets des coupes
sombres financières qui ont pesé sur nos
armées il ya depuis une dizaine d'années
jusqu'en 2014 2015
elle a perdu par exemple je crois 1600
postes en ces cinq dernières années et
donc elle est également sous tension il
est également sous tension ce service de
santé des armées
un rapport du sénat sortie mi juin
recommande d'augmenter son budget pour
pouvoir lui redonner de l'air et de
l'épaisseur de les toffes mille son
budget 1,4 milliard d'euros
donc c'est une un condensé de spécialité
et en même temps à l'échelle nationale
c'est symbolique puisque c'est 1% à peu
près de l'offre de soins nationale mais
comme vous l'avez dit avec des capacités
exceptionnelles et surtout une capacité
à capter de réactivité immédiate comme
on l'a vu avec le déploiement de
l'hôpital militaire de campagne
les militaires de réanimation le m eur à
mulhouse en mars par ce dernier une
trentaine de lits uniquement dédié à la
réanimer réanimation des patients mais
par exemple en ce moment il y à peu près
300 300 personnels du service de santé
des armées qui sont déployés sur les
théâtres d'opérations extérieures
[Musique]
là dessus en revanche beaucoup de
messages de soutien bonjour sylviane
fouquet bruyant sur la page facebook du
figaro vive la france ils les forces de
l'ordre vive l'armée
bonjour olivier bourdin qui nous
rappellent qu'ils y liberté et équité
fraternité accès lui et qui nous dit
merci merci à vous tous qui étiez au
front lors de cette pandémie
que dieu vous bénisse et vous garde
toujours bas merci pour vos messages de
soutien merci à peut l'être vino qui ne
dit immense soutien et respect à nos
militaires gendarmes pompiers policiers
voilà n'hésitez pas en tout cas à passer
tous vos messages sur la page facebook
du figaro on les prend on essaye de les
mettre en avant
n'hésitez pas aussi à me poser vos
questions à mériadec raffray
journalistes spécialisés également
secrétaire au sein de l'association des
journalistes de défense à pourra vous
apporter pas mal d'explications je pense
donc n'hésitez pas voilà raja corbel ce
qui nous divise joyeuse fête ma belle
france bah merci beaucoup à vous d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui la marine
marchande et elle qui le dit notre armée
est magnifique
bah merci à vous de vos messages on ne
vous voulez suivre ces images en direct
bien évidemment sur figaro live
alors on a on a vu défiler des écoles
prestigieuses qui forment l'élite des
cadres de l'armée de demain
mais on a vu également défilé j'ai
aperçu en particulier l'école des
mousses
c'est un mot que j'aime bien moi qui
suis d'origine bretonne et c'est une
école qui est intéressante parce
qu'elles forment des jeunes jeunes gens
jeunes femmes jeunes hommes qui sont à
peine sortis du système éducatif pour
certains qui n'ont pas forcément brillé
pour plein de raisons tard pour certains
en difficulté et cette école des mousses
il a une adresse qui a cherbourg en
quelques mois
en quelques voilà en quelques mois grâce
à un encadrement al de marins
expérimentés forme et redonne du goût
assez assez jeune jeunes français qui
pouvaient avoir souffert dans le système
scolaire les remet dans le droit chemin
entre guillemets le droit chemin
pédagogique j'entends et leur donne et
ces jeunes hommes mais ces jeunes femmes
peuvent ensuite s'engager pour servir
sur les bâtiments de la marine nationale
et ensuite
se former de manière continue comme on
dit dans les entreprises aux différentes
spécialités qu'offre la marine nationale
la marine nationale et véritable armée
de spécialistes 24e et rit on voit le
régiment défilé n'était basée à
vincennes il a une particularité c'est
que c'est seul régiment constitué de
l'armée de terre qui est à 97% composée
de réservistes donc des gens qui ont un
métier d'un civil entre guillemets et
qui le temps de leur convocation sous
les drapeaux occupe un poste officiel
dans ce régiment au porte de vincennes
[Musique]
euh warzone roland expats liberté pivert
002 bas merci à vous n'hésitez pas à
commenter nous poser toutes vos
questions ce sera avec grand plaisir
qu'on les prendra et merci à vous et
votre message au war zone qui le dit
mais salut à tous ce bond de 14 juillet
[Musique]
c'est de l'armée de l'air qui défilent
et là ça va être laissé la bride à les
pompiers de l'air par an et c'est ça
[Musique]
m
bravo thibault pour ce fin commentaire
en fait mais c'est intéressant je vais
on peut développer un peu le famas
effectivement et de le dernier fusil
d'assaut fabriqué en france qui équipent
nos armées et on a choisi pour le
remplacer le hk 416 qui est une norme
allemande qui est en cours de dotation
dans les armées et c'est un point
intéressant parce que en 2010 est enfin
2016 et puis surtout 2017 quand le même
accro arrive aux commandes le
gouvernement en fait va officialiser le
le sursaut budgétaires des années 2015
2016 pour le transformer et surtout le
pérenniser d'année en année est l'une
des demandes des armées s'est en
particulier notamment de l'armée terre
c'est en particulier de faire effort sur
les petits équipements ce finalement
qu'on ne voit pas quand on fait quand on
essaye de supprimer des des commandes
parce que les budgets en baisse
si on supprime le porte avions tout de
suite ça se voit lorsqu'on supprime des
éléments individuels c'est évidemment ça
passe plus inaperçu est en fait l'une
des demandes des soldats qui font la
guerre au quotidien c'est d'être mieux
équipée d'avoir une arme moderne d'avoir
un gilet pare-balles moderne
c'est-à-dire qu'ils soient à la fois
efficace et pas trop lourd pour pas
gêner les gêner dans le combat etc etc
et il y a une forte inquiétude
actuellement d'ailleurs de l'as partant
des chefs militaires que des des hommes
dans les régiments et sur les bateaux il
se demande si les contraintes
budgétaires fortes que connaît
actuellement la france ne vont pas une
fois de plus peser sur les promesses qui
leur ont été faites et sur ce sursaut
budgétaire qui a été compté par le
gouvernement
puis sont arrivés au pouvoir en 2017
c'est une le président bacrot n'y a pas
trop répondu hier j'ai trouvé que
c'était un élément qui avait il avait
passé sous silence alors que le les
inquiétudes sont fortes car
traditionnellement malheureusement
lorsque les choix budgétaires il fallait
faire des choix budgétaires les armées
étaient selon la formule consacrée la
variable d'ajustement au des budgets et
comme nous le rappelle lolilol 1975 hk
qui nom désigne éclore un corps en
allemand pour bien désigner ce fusil
allemand qui désormais ont remplacé les
famas
alors ces choix ont été faits par par la
direction générale de l'armement qui
gère là qu'ils les acquisitions de
matériel en lien avec les industriels on
peut déplorer qu'il n'y ait plus de
fabricants d'armes de petits calibres
français mais il n'y a plus non plus de
fabricants de munitions de petit calibre
les l'armée française s'approvisionne
aujourd'hui à l'étranger dans différents
pays y compris les pays plus ou moins
exotiques
c'est un sujet qui jusqu'à présent avait
dû passer pour anecdotique mais qui
depuis la période du creux vide l'est
beaucoup moins je crois pour les
français en tout cas ils on a compris
que pour avoir des masques quand tout le
monde on voulait si on s'approvisionner
en chine ça pouvait être compliqué et
bien le sujet peut-être aujourd'hui
exactement le même pour s'approvisionner
en munitions ou alors c'est un des
sujets je pense qui est à l'étude chez
les spécialistes militaires qui
travaillent aujourd'hui sur l'hypothèse
du retour de conflit de haute intensité
la guerre que nous menons au sahel
actuellement est une guerre qui n'est
pas une guerre de haute intensité leur
centre de la nation n'est pas l'ensemble
des armes n est pas engagé leur sens de
la nation n'est pas l'outil industriel
n'est pas engagé mais les stratèges
notamment ceux qui ont réfléchi a écrit
la revue stratégique de 2017 font le
pari je pense qu'on peut les écouter à
l'aune de ce qui se passe actuellement
dans le monde d'un retour probable décès
des deux des guerres de haute intensité
hélas ces guerres elles se font à la
fois avec les avec les armes et bien sûr
mais avec des moyens logistiques et
surtout des moyens industriels
importantes qui permettent de tenir dans
la durée
on voit actuellement les forces et en
présentant des forces de sécurité
intérieure en blanc les policiers en
bleu alors j'ai un doute non ce ne sont
pas des gens là ce sont des ce sont les
éléments des douanes je pense ou de
l'administration pénitentiaire j'avoue
que j'aimerais d'août soit l'un soit
l'autre
alors qu'on s'approche et bien de la fin
de cette cérémonie mériadeck avec un
discours en d'emmanuel macron chef des
armées président de la république doit
se faire aux alentours de midi si je ne
m'abuse
écoutez moi j'ai plutôt 13 heures 13
heures 15 à moi que c'est à moi et à moi
que ça ait changé à voir mais je baille
le je crois que le discours sera décoré
les en fait de défilés de ce moment
dommage traditionnel de la nation à ses
soldats y ait aujourd'hui cette fois
dommage à tous les combattants de la
crise sanitaire
vous savez c'est un mouvement un moment
traditionnellement de rassemblement
d'harmonie de 2 comment dirais-je de
pause politique et tout à l'heure le
président va reprendre la politique
puisqu'il va
il va donc prononcé son discours
discours du 14 juillet d'ailleurs qu'il
avait en arrivant à l'été 2007 à
l'elysée estimé inopportun pour lui
voulait rompre avec cette tradition et
donc ils ne s'étaient pas exprimés et
est là donc
au vue au regard de l'évolution de son
quinquennat
il a donc remis à l'honneur ce sport
[Musique]
et en effet j'avais j'avais je m'étais
trompé d'une heure pour le discours des
manuels maquereau en revanche j'étais
bel et bien dans les heurts pour cette
cérémonie finale qui s'intitule hommage
à la nation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peut-être un commentaire thibault si
vous le permettez je pense que ce les
militaires que l'on voit là ce sont des
militaires du service militaire adapté
le le sm a c'est un un mécanisme qui
fonctionne très bien qui permet en fait
de d'inculquer une formation à la fois
militaire et professionnels à des jeunes
et en particulier aux jeunes de nos
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
l'ess et marne un système qui coûte un
peu cher mais qui qui fonctionne bien
[Musique]
alors qu'un immense sera plus rare et
blanc arrive ici sur cette place de la
concorde qui donc est bien fut le
théâtre d'une cérémonie inédite depuis
[Musique]
ouais c'est ça je vais en train de
vérifier avec mes documents c'est bien
les hommes et les femmes du service
militaire adapté qui dont le pendant
métropolitain et le et le en fait le
service militaire volontaire qui a été
mis en place en 2015 en métropole alors
le service militaire volontaire il n'a
pas l'aspect professionnel cas le
service militaire adapté en outre-mer
mais la recette est la même et le succès
est assez est également au rendez vous
simplement on parle de quelques milliers
de jeunes a à chaque fois donc c'est un
un modèle et chanter échantillonneur et
qui coûte quand même assez cher mais qui
met en valeur en fait les comment
dirais-je le modèle d'intégration et de
formation de nos armées qui fonctionne
très bien et vous l'entendez c'est un
plot dit semences et blouse blanche qui
viennent sur la place de la concorde
pour et bien venir illustrer cette place
d'espagne dans cet hommage national
c'était le nom de cette cérémonie finale
vous le disais tout à l'heure la la
patrouille de france est passé une
première fois avec les traditionnelles
traîner bleu blanc rouge
elle va désormais passer une seconde
fois avec cette fois-ci seulement la
couleur blanche a ajouté thibault que la
patrouille de france est chevaux chez
des alphajet cet avion de conception et
de fabrication franco allemande qui
vient d'être retirée qui est l avion sur
lequel s'entraîner et se former les
jeunes pilotes de chasse donc à leur
métier de pilote de chasse a notamment à
tours et les alphajet viennent d'être
retirés du service
donc c'est un moment historique une page
historique qui se referme pour
l'armée de l'air et pour cet appareil
qui rejoint désormais les bancs des
musées et qui servira notamment à former
les jeunes mécaniciens des écoles de
mécaniciens de l'armée de l'air
[Musique]
alors que beaucoup de messages de
soutien notamment sur la page principale
du figaro on vous en remercier bravo les
hospitaliers topic news écoutez merci de
vos messages et n'hésitez pas sur
facebook sur la page principale du
figaro sur twitch a envoyé tous vos
messages de soutien à nos soignants non
pas de les applaudir à nos balcons comme
ce fut le cas pendant la crise sanitaire
mais bel et bien d'envoyer tous vos
messages de soutien
[Musique]
avec ce message véronique crespo sur
facebook
les blouses blanches ce sont des héros
du jour ils étaient au front et continue
bravo et merci à vous de votre message
n'hésitez pas si comme véronique vous
avez des messages de soutien à faire
passer nous les ferons remonter avec
grand plaisir comme le vôtre alan jalal
kylie bravo longue vie aux soignants
martin dussault qui nous dit bravo aux
soignants je les respecte en portant
toujours le masque et bien merci de vos
messages et bravo pour votre
responsabilité
le leader de 1975 bravo les soignants
également merci à vous
[Musique]
il
présentée
[Musique]
mais moi
or
duvalier
et toi
l e
il est dans la
et quand on est bon il
écossais
c
[Musique]
social
et
[Musique]
aux français
on fonce
sous nos drapeaux à croix
en
[Musique]
oh
avait eu
ce sont des emplois
[Musique]
marie c
non
[Musique]
et vous le voyez le blanc à l'honneur en
hommage aux soignants les blouses
blanches en première ligne pendant la
crise
duclos vie digne de la khl vide 19 plus
tôt et vous le soyez vous le voyez donc
cette marseillaise historique dans un
contexte sanitaire mais également
national historique
hélas thibault j'ai le gouverneur
militaire de paris le général bruno
leray qui va être je pense félicite et
remercie en tout cas par le président
mâcon comme le veut la tradition et
comme il le fait à chaque fin de défilé
en général il dit un mot surtout que
c'est donc le dernier défilé de cet
officier pour cet officier
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous en tout cas d'être toujours
avec nous je vois notamment votre
question sur sur twitch lolilol qui nous
demande qui est le compositeur de cet
arrangement de la marseillaise que vous
trouvez très beau et bien alors je n'ai
pas le nom du compositeur en tout cas
au delà de rouget de lisle bien
évidemment qui est plutôt l'auteur mais
ce que je peux vous dire en tout cas
c'est que ce tableau final qu'on a pu
observer s'appelle hommage à la nation
et bien il prend corps autour d'un grand
drapeau qui a été d'en déployer vous
l'avez vu au son de la marseillaise
interprétées par le choeur de l'armée
française et la musique de l'air qui a
participé à ce tableau a été jouée selon
une composition intitulée résilience
il
thibault c'est pour répondre à vos
interrogations des internautes on débute
défilé vous voyez que le président reste
à distance des défilants et qu'il ne va
pas leur serrer la main et ne s'approche
pas d'eux pour leur parler comme il le
fait comme il aime à le faire comme
chaque président à me le faire après les
défilés
voilà et ils en rêvaient même un masque
pour venir saluer la tribune des images
historiques on a peu l'habitude de voir
une cérémonie du 14 juillet avec bien ce
masque qui est désormais au devant de la
scène on peut le dire
à
bon
les jean castex qui portent lieu
également un masque ce masque thibault
d'un point de vue du vin pour le
commentateur le spécialiste question
défense que je suis qui est aussi le
symbole de la fragilité finalement d'une
nation d'un pays face à des risques de
l'ampleur de la pandémie et qui doivent
je pense souligné le fait que il y a
deux types de nation face à cette
fragilité ceux qui investissent à la
fois dans les structures hospitalières
de santé mais également dans leur outil
militaire celui qui doit nous protéger
lorsque tous tombent lorsque c'est le
chaos
c'est selon l'expression consacrée
le rôle de désarmer que d'être le
dernier rempart face face au danger que
quel que soit finalement la forme que ce
danger prennent aujourd'hui est une fois
de plus la revue stratégique d'ailleurs
le président l'a souligné hier soir dans
son discours en 2017 avait bien lister
tous ces dangers y compris d'ailleurs
celui de la pandémie qui avait été noté
par les stratégies militaires dans les
différents livres blancs précédent cette
revue stratégique et justement ça c'est
intéressant le commentateur spécialisé
que vous êtes
aura peut-être une réaction puisque bien
je le rappelle cette phrase importante
qui marquera peut-être l'année 2020 à
l'échelle de notre nation nous sommes en
guerre mériadeck
alors nous c'est effectivement nous
sommes alors faire nous sommes hors
guerre c'est une expression qui a fait
couler l'encré des d historia liste mais
nous sommes toujours en guerre fasse
effectivement à cette pandémie dont on
voit bien que on a du mal à la connaître
et à la comprendre
nous sommes toujours en guerre face au
terrorisme je vous rappelle qu'en ce
moment d'organes dans paraître dans
paris et dans les grandes métropoles de
français de métro et de l'outre-mer
l'opération se déroule l'opération
sentinelle qui est une opération qui
vient appuyer le travail des forces de
l'ordre pour nous protéger contre le
danger du terrorisme islamique nous
sommes en guerre au quotidien en ce
moment même des hommes font la guerre
nos hommes font la guerre au sahel
nos hommes nos aviateurs de l'opération
shamal en jordanie font la guerre nous
avons également l'opération agenor dans
le golfe persique qui veillent justement
a comme on irait bien d'instabilité de
cette zone pour l'instant un peu de moi
sous tension mais qui peut le redevenir
sans préavis et enfin nous sommes sous
les mers actuellement il ya un sous
marin nucléaire lanceur d'engins qui
avait axé sa vingtaine de missiles
nucléaires est garante de l'indépendance
de la souveraineté de la france face à
angers ultime
d'ailleurs pendant cette pandémie
l'armée de l'armée de l'air avait à a
mis en place un exercice et l'a fait
savoir discrètement et tous nos
concurrents et les états étaient à
l'ecoute l'a fait elle a mis en place un
exercice aérien pour tester et démontrer
la permanence du volet de la dissuasion
aérienne donc oui oui nous sommes en
guerre sans compter évidemment
la guerre dans l'espace le commandent le
président de la république a dit hier
que depuis 2010 est il avait créé le
commandement militaire de l'espace à
toulouse dans l'espace et puis
évidemment dans le cinquième élément qui
est le le cyberespace actuellement
également il y à des militaires
spécialisés dans la cyberdéfense et la
cyberattaque qui veille et qui nous
protège dans ce cyber espace qui a fait
l'objet également de plusieurs attaques
à noter pendant cette période
particulière du confinement tout à fait
inquiets
1 représente le cyberespace et
l'information présente tout simplement
l'inde est l'un des points cruciaux de
la guerre moderne actuelle
on a donc désormais mériadeck eh bien
ces images du président de la république
accompagné par jean castex et olivier
ferrand ce n'est pas rien c'est pas un
symbole c'est un simple symbole le
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
le premier ministre tous deux viennent
de signer le ségur de la santé hier on a
pu suivre ces images en direct sur
figaro live et donc toutes ces personnes
qui portent un masque pour ces échanges
je vous le rappelle dans les tribunes
aujourd'hui même si le nombre de
spectateurs est particulièrement limitée
avec 2195 participants seulement sur
place soit deux fois moins que l'année
dernière
pour thibaut 2195 c'est le nombre de
militaires ont tout 5000 ha pardon
voilà 2195 c'est le nombre de militaires
et le reste est composé d'environ 500
personnels de sécurité les médias etc et
le solde est composé des invités des
alizés dont en majorité les personnels
soignants et tous ses métiers ses
fonctionnaires et ses métiers qui ont
qui n'ont pas débaucher pendant la crise
depuis les éboueurs jusqu'aux agents
d'edf qui ont géré les réseaux
d'électricité etc etc
voilà merci beaucoup de ces précisions
c'est vrai que les chiffres sont assez
nombreux il faut les il faut les prendre
dans le calme il faut et donc moins de
deux mois de la jauge était à moins de
5000 donc pour respecter le décret en
vigueur sur les rassemblements en
période non plus d'urgence sanitaire
puisqu'on n'y est plus depuis le 10
juillet mais
les bras semblant one 5000 personnes au
delà ce ne sont toujours pas autorisés
eh bien nous arrivons à la fin de cette
cérémonie mériadeck
un grand merci pour toutes ces
explications claires
les rendez vous ne sont pas terminés
puisque à 13h on doit avoir un discours
particulièrement attendu de la part du
président de la république
merci thibault merci à tous les
internautes d'avoir suivi ce matin et
voilà en tout cas on vous donne
rendez-vous je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialisé défense et que
vous êtes secrétaire général de
l'association des journalistes de
défense on vous remercie profondément
pour toutes ces explications et d'avoir
suivi avec nous cette célébration du 14
juillet un petit peu spéciale pour la
première fois depuis 1945
le défilé militaire traditionnel n'était
pas tout à fait représenter on était
plutôt dans une cérémonie d'hommage aux
soignants en cette période de crise
sanitaire historique qui continuent
d'être assez représentative avec ce
nombre de personnes portant un masque
vous le voyez sur la tribune moi je vous
donne rendez vous à 13 heures on va
suivre en direct le discours d' emmanuel
macron le président de la république et
le chef des armées
on va pouvoir suivre les enjeux de cette
de ce discours en direct donc n'hésitez
pas à nous retrouver sur la page
principale du figaro sur facebook mais
également sur twitter et ensuite et bien
le programme de la journée n'est lui
aussi pas terminé puisque de 10 heures à
12 heures il y avait un appel de
manifestations et gilet jaune devant
l'igpn
mais surtout et bien une manifestation
est appelée à 14 heures de la place de
la république à celle de la bastille de
la part des soignants qui eux s'estiment
lésés en cette période de signature hier
de la crise 2
du ségur de la santé eh bien on essaiera
de suivre cela sur le figaro en page
principale n'hésitez pas à vous y rendre
tu veux souhaiter bien voir un petit peu
comment se passe ce rassemblement et
surtout bien évidemment ce soir à 23
heures le traditionnel concert puis les
feux d'artifice qui eux par contre se
feront sans spectateurs on sait que
d'habitude c'est un rendez vous prisé
des touristes mais également des
parisiens et français et bien on pourra
suivre en tout cas ces images en direct
moi je vous donne rendez vous très vite
sur figaro live donc à 13h pour le
discours d' emmanuel macron et je vous
dis à très bientôt sur figaro l'est